[Music]
at any given moment trillions of cells
are traveling through your blood vessels
sometimes circling the body in just one
minute each of these cells has its
origins deep in your bones bones might
seem rock solid but they're actually
quite porous inside large and small
blood vessels enter through these holes
and inside most of the large bones of
your skeleton is a hollow core filled
with soft bone marrow marrow contains
fat and other supportive tissue but its
most essential elements of blood stem
cells these stem cells are constantly
dividing they can differentiate into red
blood cells white blood cells and
platelets and send hundreds of billions
of new blood cells into circulation
every day these new cells enter the
bloodstream through holes in small
capillaries in the marrow through the
capillaries they reach larger blood
vessels and exit the bone if there's a
problem with your blood there's a good
chance it can be traced back to the bone
marrow blood cancers often begin with
genetic mutations in the stem cells the
stem cells themselves are not cancerous
but these mutations can interfere with
the process of differentiation and
result in malignant blood cells so for
patients with advanced blood cancers
like leukemia and lymphoma the best
chance for a cure is often an allogenic
bone-marrow transplant which replaces
the patient's bone marrow with the
donors here's how it works
first blood stem cells are extracted
from the donor most commonly blood stem
cells are filtered out of the donors
blood stream by circulating the blood
through a machine that separates it into
different components in other cases the
marrow is extracted directly from a bone
in the hip the iliac crest with the
needle meanwhile the recipient prepares
for the transplant high doses of
chemotherapy or radiation kill the
patient's existing marrow destroying
both malignant cells and blood stem
cells this also weakens the immune
system making it less likely to attack
the transplanted cells then the donor
cells are infused into the patient's
body through a central line they
initially circulate in the recipients
peripheral blood stream but molecules on
the stem cell
called chemokines act as homing devices
and quickly trafficked them back to the
marrow over the course of a few weeks
they begin to multiply and start
producing new healthy blood cells just a
small population of blood stem cells can
regenerate a whole body's worth of
healthy marrow a bone marrow transplant
can also lead to something called graft
versus tumor activity when new immune
cells generated by the donated marrow
can wipe out cancer cells the recipients
original immune system couldn't this
phenomenon can help eradicate stubborn
blood cancers but bone marrow
transplants also come with risks
including graft-versus-host disease it
happens when the immune system generated
by the donor cells attacks the patient's
organs this life-threatening condition
occurs in about 30 to 50 percent of
patients who receive donor cells from
anyone other than identical twin
particularly when the stem cells are
collected from the blood as opposed to
the bone marrow patients may take
immunosuppressant medications or certain
immune cells may be removed from the
donated sample in order to reduce the
risk of graft-versus-host disease but
even if a patient avoids
graft-versus-host disease their immune
system may reject the donor cells so
it's crucial to find the best match
possible in the first place
key regions of the genetic code
determine how the immune system
identifies foreign cells if these
regions are similar in the donor and the
recipient
the recipients immune system is more
likely to accept the donor cells because
these genes are inherited the best
matches are often siblings but many
patients who need a bone marrow
transplant don't have a matched family
member those patients turn to donor
registries of volunteers willing to
offer their bone marrow all it takes to
be on the registry is a cheek swab to
test for a genetic match and in many
cases the donation itself isn't much
more complicated than giving blood it's
a way to save someone's life
with a resource that's completely
renewable
if you'd like to join a bone marrow
registry
you can visit be the match dog to get
started or to find a list of affiliated
registries around the world
[Music]